you wanted to spice your pasta up and  that's why you put some tabasco sauce  and now you are thinking it's too much  and it's giving you a burning sensation  question is how to cool down  the good old technique is to drink some  milk  do you know the science behind that why  you should drink drink milk  it is actually the noble weaning work of  david julius and arjun pataputin they  got this nobel prize in 2021 for  discovering the receptors for  temperature and touch the active  substances in chile is known as  capsaicin  capsaicin can potentially bind to a  receptor known as strip v1  this actually stimulates the nerve cell  and you feel that pain sensation  luckily capsaicin is soluble in lipids  that's why when you drink water it kind  of wash that extra capsis in a way and  relieves the pain  drinking water would not help in this  case  that's one minute see you in next video